so this is the fifth time that you've
done the Captain America how did you
feel when you stepped into it this time
a lot more comfortable you know the
first couple times you're terrified you
want to make sure that you pay the
character the right respect that it
deserves but but you know now that we've
I feel a little bit more comfortable
doing it it's it's exciting and it just
feels it feels like home now a little
bit uh so your character goes on a
different and unexpected moral journey
in this film how did it feel as an actor
to explore this side of Captain America
further it was great you know they
always make Capps decisions very um he's
a very binary guy you know it's this or
that I mean he's he's black and white
and this is the first time it's kind of
been an uncertain decision in terms of
what the right move is and it's it's
it's self-serving so it was exciting to
kind of see him have a struggle that
wasn't so clear he was exciting for me
to do Sanga um how does the relationship
between Steve Rogers and Bucky Barnes
play out in this particular story it's
very relevant you know it's it's it's a
very personal struggle for Steve Steve
always tries to take his emotions out of
the equation he always tried to think of
the greater good when it comes to Bucky
it's a very personal situation and so
it's easy to become human and to let
your emotions fog and cloud your
judgment and and Bucky represents
something from his past that no one else
can match I don't care how strong his
bonds are with his current family
Bucky's his original family and and that
that can take presidents so you made two
Avengers movies where the Avengers
fought shoulder to shoulder United but
what was it like to film the battle
scene where you guys are going against
each other sure sure even though we
fought we even though we filmed movies
where the Avengers are all United
filming a movie where the Avengers are
crumbling from within is it's strange
but but exciting because you know that
the stakes are going to be cranked
higher than they ever could have been
prior yeah this is this is and it's far
more akin to obstruction life you know I
think anyone can agree that a fight you
have with your enemies nowhere near as
dramatic as
but you have a family member you know
when when it's when it's someone you
simultaneously hate and love I mean it
just makes it that much more complex who
is on Team cap and who isn't that you
wish was sure on team cap we have me we
have Falcon we have Scarlet Witch we
have ant-man we have I was gonna say
Sebastian man's Winter Soldier
we have Hawkeye who do I wish were on
Team cap you know uh Hulk would be nice
he would really just bat cleanup and
just take care of this whole mess that
would be pretty dope and uh so was there
any friendly rivalry between team cap
and team Iron Man off screens sure uh I
don't think so again we're all so close
and we've all done multiple movies
together now I mean it's it's funny to
even come to set and remember oh yeah
we're not on the same I fight you do I
fight you tomorrow you know it's it's a
strange thing because again we're all so
used to making these movies together as
a unit and doing press as a unit it's
it's strange to come to work and
remember oh yeah we're on opposing sides
tomorrow aren't we um you know so so no
I it didn't feel too much like the the
rivalry carried offset just and also for
my own edification like you guys slam on
each other so much we're there any
stunts mishaps this time there are some
tricky things you know cuz a lot of
these characters are physical fighters
you know it's not an Ironman vision guys
like Thor these are all CGI based combat
characters but Black Panther Winter
Soldier
Hawkeye myself these are characters that
fight with hand-to-hand combat so when
you have these giant running scenes you
need to hit you need to collide um and
you know there's a few I saw a few stunt
men take a few nasty stumbles you know
like really really hitting the ground
hard and brutally you know it's it's
tall movie did you learn any new
techniques for this film specifically a
new techniques for this film um no our
Winter Soldier is where I really tried
to kind of broaden my
palate in terms of skillset you know
with regards to park warden gymnastics
and jumping and flipping but a lot of
that stuff stuck so it was pretty easy
to kind of pick it back up on this one
you took it a lot easier on doors in
this film and I was really happy for
every door and that's nice that's nice
hey just turn the knob dude so uh what
was can you talk about working with Joe
and Anthony Russo on the best film
specifically yeah great I mean it's the
biggest thing in my opinion for an actor
on set is trusting your director as an
actor the worst thing you can do is play
safe the worst thing you can do is go to
set and think this is how I this is my
instinct and I'm only going to stick to
my instinct and and you know if we have
three or four takes I'm only going to
use these takes to get on film what I
think the character needs the best stuff
comes from those risks and those chances
in the the stuff when you kind of put
yourself out there and you don't tend to
do that when you don't trust your
director and and I should make it a
negative when you trust your director
that's when you go for it that's when
you really take chances and and the best
thing about Anthony and Joe is that I
trust them so completely so fully that
I'm willing to just say listen we do one
more I'm just gonna try something if you
don't like you don't like it I don't
have to worry that you're gonna use it
incorrectly I mean how you felt with
that upgraded costume did it inform the
way you play the guy well it was great
you know when you step into a Tony Stark
Erised costume it just make you feel
more machismo you know it's like you
just walk in you go yo I'm sexy Sexy's
here that's just when I know
yep see you your character is very
dramatic this time around it very
interesting to watch you play he's
continuing to evolve remember his past
and there's a lot of complexity so was
that exciting for you to play that or
did you want some of the lines that he
gets no I was I was happy with what I
had to do in the film you know I thought
and then but yes I did appreciate
anything any interaction I had with
Falcon I really enjoy
especially throwing punches at him he
cleans up pretty well doesn't he yeah I
know I don't always look homeless he's
up but it's it is a you know steel blue
eyes let you know where home is you know
what I'm talking about that's my safe
place and open your eyes like that Peter
gray girls oh you're both on team cap
was it great to just be paired up again
with Chris Evans hey what you know is
fun um the three of us about I'm not
going to speak for Sebastian but I'll
say it's really great when you come
around to people after a year a year and
a half even two years and it's like one
minute hasn't passed you know as Chris
and Sebastian really have a way of
working hard and being smart and humble
and not letting ego any of this
Hollywood stuff get in the way of what's
important and that's something that I
admire and work towards as well so it's
just always fun to work together that's
nice to hear no I mean I think everybody
don't make me take it back the best out
of each other but you know you'd like
when I heard that I was going to a show
with you I was like oh like it's gonna
be great you know you know that right
off the bat nice so there are physical
requirements so how long before the
filming starts you just stop eating or
whatever it is you have to do I was
eating chicken breasts at 3 a.m. after I
was peeing from sending a lot of water
throughout the day in January and we
were starting to shoot an April you
forget I got I got up to 200 pounds yeah
yeah I do 14 weeks that's that's my date
from first day of shooting I'll take 14
weeks cut my diet cut my social life and
they were like your daily life period
and start working towards Wow well it
works uh yeah we assume has to fit and
ain't no muscle suits under those
costumes as all us that's nice all right
cool you go to Germany and when you're
ever on a location I'm just guessing
that that makes life or working a little
bit more a real or
it's not a soundstage you're in a great
city you tell me if that informed your
performances I mean I think it you know
it any location in my opinion feels like
another opportunity for all of us
especially like oh we're in Germany
great we're here it's a cast together
great like one time off or we go to
dinner we can just tell me we can get a
drink it just forms our sort of commader
II and that ends up making it to the
screen you know so I just think it's
another way of bonding together so there
are some key moments there so that's why
I asked especially being in Germany
Germany was a very unique place it still
is amazing and Berlin specifically this
is really it informed me a lot as an
individual just because there's so much
art so much history so much culture
there and shooting there was really a
privilege so there's this epic battle
and you're going up against this other
team and these are people you like is
that the most fun shooting or it's like
oh I don't want to do that to him I
don't want to do that to her
I think everyone uh in this movie waits
for an opportunity to punch someone on
the other team in the team yeah yeah no
I'm supposed to laugh I think I think
Jeremy's you talked any much like man I
really want to go at him what was your
reaction when you saw the Black Panther
in the suit because it's quite
spectacular ank God I'm not wearing that
I mean that first reactions second
reaction opposite coming at you is oh
god oh god he looks so hot he looks so
hot but not like a hundred and ten
degrees not hot like JLo like high what
was it like being with the Russo
brothers again do you think you're in
the groove because you work with them
before or did they throw new things at
you they're always evolving as directors
just like we're always evolving as
actors um you know there's a certain
shorthand I feel like we've all
developed now because we work together
so much that's fun and easy they know
our personalities so well now that they
can see when we're going on a good path
and when we're going
went on a panthan eMac attention so they
just got to wrangle us in and get us on
a good path so it's cool you don't get
that ever as an actor unless you're you
know one of the huge star actors you
don't get that opportunity so it's great
when he's talking you're thinking like
you were reliving the whole experience
or some just now yeah you were yeah man
I was know what I was really like where
I just went was I just remembered
sitting and we were doing press stuff
just like this for the Winter Soldier
movie and I was supposed to and I'm I
saw like when it was the Winter Soldier
and I thought about Joe and Anthony then
and how we were making that movie and
just we were all just trying to figure
out kind of like we didn't know what you
know we know what we wanted the movie to
be but you know you're always kind of
like how are we going to work together
whatever and then fast forward it's just
a little bit crazy to be better with
them right right again now you know it's
when I was like three years ago what can
fans expect when they see Captain
America Civil War fans can expect a
character script driven drama I think
what's interesting and different about
this movie is the action sequences are
secondary and when you see the movie
you're so drawn into the characters that
the action sequences become more
important because there is that aspect
of fatality there is that aspect of
mortality and that's what makes it so
exciting because you might lose your
favorite superhero yeah it's it's fun
and suspenseful it's action-packed or at
the edge of your seat and there's not a
real clear bad guy that's enough you can
you're going to see really two strong
sides that are gonna you're going to be
in your chair going I don't know who to
root for because I get his point of view
and I get what that guy is doing and it
makes it hard it makes it for a good
dramatic conflict all the bad stuff is
justify does it feel that have the
Scarlet Witch now be part of the
Avengers and did that dynamic bring
something different to the character
this time around yeah I think I mean
there's a lot of things that I was able
to play with it this started the film
just even like how much she is adapted
to living in more of a Western world how
does that affect her dress how does that
fact her accent like just things like
that I get a geek out on the specifics
of maybe no one else would recognize but
I it's fun for me and then also to have
a great journey written for her and um
for her to be conflicted about how to
use her abilities or when to use them in
this film is it was was a nice thing to
play um very quickly in this film she's
she's in a difficult position yes she is
yeah yes she is but I wrote down
kick-ass by the way about you
early on when I was watching it so
Jeremy you have this relationship now
between Hawkeye and Scarlett here hmm um
what was this new friendship like for
you to play fun that's the word I'm
thinking yeah I mean I think there's it
kind of stemming coming off of all
trauma and into this you know it they
get it wasn't a lot to explore I think
there's a lot more to explore and I
think it dynamic is really sort of
interesting to where I don't know if
it's if it's a yeah like a sort of
Brotherly your uncle type of thing you
kind of looking up where she's the more
powerful like monster creature this
chest I think probably was powerful in
the universe and then is me there's no
powers but she I don't know there's an
interesting dynamic between and I think
there's definitely replacement on her
end of life she's only person she and
her life was her brother know after
parents you know she is no one and um
and he for some reason feels like
someone who really saw her through all
of that yeah especially with Quicksilver
says family ties to a kind of thing yeah
brother can interesting things to kind
of look into you hit on the custom a
little bit it inspired your inner
superhero at all um yeah you use the
words geek out earlier so I'm guessing
yes um I'm getting more excited every
time we got to create more of a
superhero classmates my first time
getting to be in a superhero we did for
that one second at the end of Ultron but
this is my first time wearing superhero
costume and part of me was like well
when do they go and change like how fast
does that work
and I just kind of had to ignore that
but um yeah it was really cool to create
a new silhouette for her um a new image
journey you can be a tough guy and now
this is more hand-to-hand combat for you
this time out did you like that more
yeah yeah I mean yeah that's what I like
about the character um because
everything is pretty practical you know
there's no special powers of flying or
donating that's you can't just do his
hands or feet or zero so I'm always
about that but it's an attitude too you
have to have that attitude to be
confident that you will survive whatever
these crazy epic battles oh you don't
you know oh you know that's that's
that's but also that's why I like it
because he brings in that sort of again
if you got any more you know should they
connect with anything at the Scarlet
Witch is about oh I hope so
um I hope people I mean I think there's
a lot to connect with with everyone's
character doesn't matter what side
you're on
I think that's what makes these films so
much fun to watch and so and for Alling
for so many people because everyone kind
of attaches for whatever reason to one
or two characters and it's because
hopefully they're these fully fleshed
out people with with flaws and have to
go through difficulty and overcome it
what was it like when you stepped onto
that tarmac to film that big epic battle
if I thought it was it was really
interesting ready there is a logic
coordinate for some of the wider shots
of like at this point you know Sebastian
does this and you do this if spider-man
does this you're kind of like oh my
goodness and that's kind of exciting to
see how you could see how it could kind
of conduct connect and editing pieces
things like that yeah I mean of coolest
part was like you know were kind of
lined up into things the rest it's like
so destroyed so many pieces that you
know a lot of a lot of CGI happening
here with Maria but it was nice to stand
as a team that was fun what's cool yeah
yeah I agree I mean it's I felt like you
didn't want to hurt each other but it
was time to punch it so yeah exactly
exactly exactly take family fight rock
you said that every film should have two
directors he felt that experience was
great what was it like for you with
these Russo brothers
yeah I mean they could they could be one
could be on the crew and we talking to
that actors especially like for a movie
this size and there's so many learn
storylines as so many characters and try
to please the fans and try to serve the
actors and the story I mean there's a
lot going on for any one person how Josh
was doing it have no idea
he's probably retired now because they
put it but we should buzz together work
together very well yeah and it's a
really real joy to work those guys
you